Vania three summer vacation including
Jim Gaffigan good to see you sir to see
a thing I have here in my hand this is a
noble ape is in theaters correct it's in
the--it's it's in theaters it's on
demand it's on iTunes on Amazon
everywhere you rent or buy okay
and in my hands yes vinyl is this vinyl
like an actual Lionel yes this is a you
know vinyls or a big thing now other
people are really into vinyls you know
some people collect them I think in this
age of digital yes owning something
that's you can physically hold and then
you you know you you know the Barry
Blankenship was the artist that did all
this stuff and yes it's kind of this fun
artistic thing it's a very van Gogh
looking Jim yes it is very van Gogh when
I do only see one year actually you only
see one year is that specific that was
it was just this strange idea some of it
was my beard I felt like the idea
started kind of I have a joke about
looking like a Civil War general that's
out of shape and so this kind of shifted
it but it eventually turned into Van
Gogh who did you have a vinyl comedy
album from growing up what did you have
on vinyl I was the youngest of six kids
so we didn't have much of anything but I
would listen to Steve Martin and Bill
Cosby and you know of course Karlin yes
oh yeah now I remember
you know just lifting up the needle like
the gentleness you had to place it down
and you know you're a clumsy
eight-year-old you don't know what I'm
sure I ruined most of them I'm
definitely gonna date myself and I know
for a fact Brockman you're not gonna
know who the hell I'm talking about
I had Alan Schurman albums hello mother
hello father
yeah Here I am at Camp Grenada yeah I
listen to Alan Schurman as a kid that's
on race on vinyl yeah I mean some of it
is also I was the youngest of six so I
have some you know my brothers and
sisters had albums that I don't know if
I would have been aware of you know like
elo and you know some of these musicians
that
you know that was their heyday was the
album and now you have five kids I have
five kids they're not listening to squat
on vinyl right no no they're you know
it's it changes every five years that's
why this special was released everywhere
because how specials and comedy is
consumed changes every couple years I
know that everyone assumes Netflix it's
like I've been doing press and they're
like it's on Netflix I'm like no this
one's actually everywhere but Netflix
but it'll change in three years you know
I'll be back here and you'll be like is
it on this platform because it'll change
now
I know your kids travel with you right
yes how the hell do you do that
you know Jim Gaffigan because they range
from what five five to fourteen fourteen
how do you do it's it's insane and
instancing you know and there's plenty
of moments where you know look they're
not with me now and when I travel
without my children in between those
moments of guilt are just hours of
happiness just joy and euphoria but I
usually construct tour dates where my
family can come with me over Christmas I
did a bunch of shows in the Florida and
then my my family came down and my
wife's family also came down because
they didn't want us to have a good time
but I totally understand what you're
saying you know where there's guilt yeah
but and then you know for the first 24
hours there's pure joy there I missed
them then there's guilt then the guilt
sets in yeah so at what point is the
guilt begin to dissipate and then the
pure unadulterated constant joy sighs
you know for me kids Jim like you know
do you know traveling flying across the
country people complain about it I'm
like that is the best I get to sleep I
get to watch a movie it's like a
vacation it is a vacation it's amazing I
just came off of a week of it's a trip
right it's a vacation when when you're
not with your kids right I just came off
a week-long trip with my wife and I
actually started the show with this on
on Monday in Washington DC
the most difficult thing of all time in
my mind is attempting to get three
children you have five yeah to take a
photograph
oh it's in said well I have any advice
for me on on how to meet all bribery
right I had my kids I brought five kids
a we're in I did shows in Europe to the
Anne Frank House
I brought my 5 7 9 12 and 14 year old 12
and 14 year old understood you know a
five and a seven year old they don't
understand this and you know the
seriousness the this sombering
atmosphere of the end Frank house like
my seven-year-old it's like do they have
Wi-Fi here here don't ask that at the
Anne Frank House you don't do that at
the end Frank House and but it's by the
way I should point out the Anne Frank
House I bought tickets online hmm I
googled it there are the Anne Frank
House has four point four out of five
stars who is giving a bad review to the
Anne Frank House it's like yeah I
thought it was kind of boring is kind of
crowded you know it's just didn't say
isn't saying it's insane I went to the
Anne Frank House with my buddies this is
way before I was married with children
in a row I made the mistake of doing the
Heineken tour before it oh my god I want
to talk about instant sobering yeah you
know that was uh I missed a great buzz
from the Heineken Tour and then yeah
that's that'll cure abuzz right well
maybe those are the people who didn't
give it the five stars by the way you
know we were talking about traveling
with family yes Otto Frank with his
family for two years like he didn't get
to leave no iPad either no I mean it's
so it's so creepy you can't even joke
around about it I know but I'm trying to
figure out it no but none of the listen
there are certain ones where you just
leave it there but yeah that's the whole
thing with my three kids just they
couldn't they could not just sit still
couldn't stand over so do you have some
pictures well you know what I yes I do
but then you have to delete the other
twelve of the single just to get the one
just you know there's high-class
problems
yeah yeah right I mean what did what did
our parents did
because it's like ours is just not
digital they didn't even know if it was
a good picture back then but that's why
Polaroids were so fast you can actually
see what it looks like oh my gosh and
they're all started with a conversation
about a vinyl a vinyl version of noble
ape what is this about for those who may
not know so this special is it really
encompasses the last year of my life
which is been insane
you know last April was discovered by my
wife had a brain tumor and going through
that experience and then some traveling
and I mean I love stand-up comedy I feel
like I I keep getting better at it and
it's just kind of rewarding to kind of
pull it together in a year how is your
wife now
she's great I mean she's 80% of her
which is you know normal humans 120% but
it's it's an amazing it's an amazing
journey you know we're very lucky all of
us right here are very lucky I mean
there was you know a year ago is sitting
in a hospital you know or shuttling my
wife to some doctor's appointment it
makes you really appreciate you know how
we are and how you can now you know
nowadays all around begging people to
buy it you go begging the people to buy
get it on the vinyl Jim Gaffigan noble
ape and then Hotel Transylvania 3 summer
vacation I want to take a 60-second
break come back and talk about your
ESPYs experience so sure and then you
know what you what inside information
from Jim Gaffigan on Nick Foles his
future oh yes well figure it all out
back in 60 seconds all right welcome
back to the Rich Eisen show another
segment here with Jim Gaffigan you can
again check out noble ape and theatres
or everywhere that's not Netflix
essentially pretty much you were on the
stage at the ESPYs yes any goods
backstage stories anything good what do
you got for me it's I mean it's I think
it's it's the tallest group of people
don't ever be around right and obviously
everyone's in shape my joke when I was
on stage was like they probably just had
me there so that the curling guys could
feel in shape
but it is it's it's very it's very
impressed because these are all so
everyone at the top of their respective
sport so it was pretty pretty
intimidating but also you know they're
regular men and women here I mean in the
end they were excited to see Aaron
Rodgers and you know all these other
people but I thought it was interesting
you know Nick Foles was there I
presented for Best Performance in a
championship game or series and he won
and I handed it's passing like is he
like what does he go into next year
right so like well you don't have any
information I don't you know I didn't
ask him I know I did not I didn't feel
like it was appropriate
you would tell a comedian you know who
talks about food and being lazy I don't
know if he'd be like you know what
I guess I'll reveal this even though
like it probably is incredibly awkward
and everyone looks at him like what
about next year what are you gonna do
how's the house right how's the throwing
arm of your teammate you're I mean
mm-hmm so like but what do you think I
think yes let me ask you in that I'll
answer yes I think that in pre-season
someone's gonna get like someone's gonna
have to step up and give a draft pick to
get him why did the Eagles the last time
they were in a situation I guess in a
way similar to this yeah where Carson
Wentz was on a roster and I had other
quarterbacks they were planning on
starting the quarterback other than
Carson Wentz but that's because he was
just fresh into the league right right
somebody else got hurt and they traded
away Sam Bradford and the rest is kind
of now history that Carson Wentz is
become Carson Wentz it's entirely
possible in another situation like that
crops up and they flip Nick Foles but I
mean when's his knees still you know in
a brace one would think it is so the
whole I don't know I think they're gonna
definitely hold on to him and it's
possible he even starts the first game
of the year nice it's also one of those
things where athletes can go through so
you know like how you
come back from an injury like rg3 I mean
that's he came back too soon
he definitely came back too and so but
some to some people you you know you are
at a certain level and it's it's a it
might be just physically you just can't
get back to where you were I mean you
see receivers lose a step and it's like
they go from you know will pay you
anything to play to like we're cutting
you yeah it's pretty damn harsh it's
brutal I know it is so brutal which is
why I guess you know you need to strike
it but that's why I will never give an
athlete grief for trying to get his or
her own in a contract just go ahead and
get whatever the hell you want whatever
the hell you think you can but I think I
think they're gonna stick with foals on
the team
the minute that Wentz is ready to go
they're gonna stick him out there and
you know see what they can get yeah they
should be able to get it first well you
know there's the defensive coordinator
of the Philadelphia Eagles is Jim
Schwartz is it true you played football
I played football with Jim Schwartz and
at Georgetown at Georgetown University
I was alignment he was a defensive back
I mean he's not that big of a guy by the
way where she look at you with that neck
roll they were showing it like look at
that old that was like I was Greg Olson
for college before and after because
that was like when I was sitting there
thinking of like I like walking out on
the ass because there's just no one
knows who I am that's not true I was
like I was walking out there and I was
like like I was either gonna do like the
thing about the curling guys or I was
gonna be like this is what Greg Olson
will look like this is your future Greg
Olson you're staring into the future
look at that toilet the padding yeah
that was the thing so you played with
Jim Schwartz I played with Jim Schwartz
and by the way the Jim Schwartz and I
were both people thought we had
pie-in-the-sky ideas what do you mean
like he wanted to be a coach mm-hm and I
wanted like I don't think you know like
like in college if he said I would like
to be professional football coach
people would laugh at him and if I said
I wanted to be a comedian people would
have laughed at me it's just it's
unrealistic so there is some there's a
bonding there and I I've run into him a
couple times I think we actually kind of
vacation near each other too but I have
no life and then also by the way no life
it's like these NFL coaches oh yeah I
know I mean it's insane it is insane
it's insane they're right now they're
about to become off vacation and then
for ten months for ten months yes yes
sir that is fact that's that is fact and
they love it and they live they they
sleep breathe study well comedians
lawyers aren't frequently very glamorous
because you're constantly working your
ass off - yeah but you know some of it
is I have to concentrate on peaking at
nine o'clock at night so like one of my
assignments for the day is to nap you
know that's a little different from like
developing a defensive scheme against
the latest surprise offense do I mean
yeah or figuring it out at halftime
because it didn't work the first half
well they also have to peak at 9 o'clock
at night - I guess Monday Night Football
and then have to do that London game
you're blessed did the London do the
London Games but just seems like just
brutal like the Jacksonville Jaguars
they're like can we just get rid of that
because then we hey they go over there I
joke all the time Blake bortles at
quarterback he's like the Jerry Lewis of
football in the fact that a European
team thinks that their that the European
audience thinks that he's the greatest
of all time he goes over there he balls
out when he goes to London he way
portals you know it was interesting I
was in Ireland it is so fascinating how
Gaelic Rules Football how huge it is
and I like that's like I always thought
soccer would be the huge sport in all
countries but like Gaelic rules football
what is Gaelic rules football it is
similar to Australian rules football
it's GAA but that's is depends on the
county in Ireland but that's bigger than
soccer
in Ireland it's like this Oh like they
have GAA they have rugby and then they
have soccer and yet they've still gotten
teams in the world kale ik rules
football yeah never and then they have
hurling and drinking drinking and
hurling pretty much so Hotel
Transylvania three number one movie in
America that was very cool yeah and I
play a van Helsing which is not good for
a battle-ax yeah
not good for Dracula but I got to bring
my kids to see me it's the first time my
five-year-olds ever been impressed cuz
they don't know what I do and so he was
like that's you that's your voice and I
was like yeah that's me and he was like
you're alright yeah before you sucked
now you don't you're alright before you
were just some fat guy that ate too much
of the pizza you know I call that you
know to my house I call that the daddy
tax yeah there you go that's what I got
they get so pissed off they now they
start screaming me don't know no daddy
tax
no daddy text yeah maybe that'll be the
next album for that'll be the next out
it's a good album
no daddy tax or no daddy tell it'll talk
about it it congratulations on this sir
thanks so much
noble ape check it out and then check
out Jim Gaffigan as well in Hotel
Transylvania 3 summer vacation you're
welcome here anytime you work too much
you got stuff going on I live in the
wrong City I'd come back keep more off
where you live in New York I live in New
York and then this happens too early
exhausted schools starting teacher
conferences with five kids it's like oh
god there's one every day you can't even
keep it straight
yeah it's too much Jim Gaffigan here and
the Rich Eisen Church follow him on
Twitter at Jim Gaffigan thank you the
Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern
on audience